so here I want to talk about the
gradient in the context of a contour map
so let's say we have a multivariable
function a two variable function f of X
Y and this one is just going to equal x
times y so we can visualize this with a
contour map just on the XY plane so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go over
here I'm going to draw my y-axis and my
x-axis right so this right here
represents X values this represents Y
values and this is entirely the input
space and I have a video on contour maps
if you are unfamiliar with them are
feeling uncomfortable and the contour
map for x times y looks something like
this and each one of these lines
represents a constant value so you might
be thinking that you have you know let's
say you want to the constant value for f
of x times y is equal to 2 would be one
of these lines that would be what one of
these lines represents and the way you
could think about that for this specific
function is you're saying hey when is x
times y equal to 2 and let's kind of
like the graph y equals 2 over X and
that's that's where you would see C
something like this so all of these
lines they're representing constant
values for the function and now I want
to take a look at the gradient field
and the gradient if you'll remember is
just a vector full of the partial
derivatives of F and let's just actually
write it out the gradient of F with our
little del symbol is a function of x and
y and it's a vector valued function
whose first coordinate is the partial
derivative of F with respect to X and
the second component is the partial
derivative with respect to Y so when we
actually do this for our function we
take the partial derivative with respect
to X it takes a look X looks like a
variable Y looks like a constant the
derivative of this whole thing is just
equal to that constant Y and then kind
of the reverse for when you take the
partial derivative with respect to Y Y
looks like a variable X looks like a
constant and the derivative is just that
constant X and this can be visualized as
a vector
filled in the xy-plane as well you know
at every given point XY so you kind of
go like x equals 2 y equals 1 let's say
so that would be x equals 2 y equals 1
you would plug in the vector and see
what should the output and at this point
the point is 2 1 the desired output kind
of swaps those so we're looking somehow
to draw the vector 1 2 so you would
expect to see the vector that has an X
component of 1 and a Y component of 2
something like that but it's probably
going to be scaled down because of the
way we usually draw vector fields and
the entire field looks like this so I'll
go ahead and erase what I had going on
since this is a little bit clearer and
remember we scale down all the vectors
the color represents length so red here
is super long blue is going to be kind
of short and one thing worth noticing if
you take a look at all of the given
points around if the vector is crossing
a contour line its perpendicular to that
contour line wherever you go you know go
down here this vector is perpendicular
to the contour line over here
perpendicular to the contour line and
this this happens everywhere and it's
for a very good reason and it's also
super useful so let's just let's just
think about what that reason should be
let's let's zoom in on a point so I'm
going to clear up our function here
clear up all the information about it
and just zoom in on one of those points
so let's say like right here I'll take
that guy and kind of imagine zooming in
and saying what's going on in that
region so you've got some kind of
contour line and it's swooping down like
this and that represents some kind of
value let's say that represents the
value F equals 2 and you know it might
not be a perfect straight line but the
more you zoom in the more it looks like
a straight line and when you wouldn't
want to interpret the gradient vector if
you remember in the video about how to
interpret the gradient in the context of
a graph I said it points in the
direction of steepest descent so if you
imagine all the possible vectors kind of
pointing away from this point the
question is which direction should you
move to increase the value of F the
fastest and there's two ways of thinking
about that one is to look at all of
these different directions and say which
one increases X the
but another way of doing it would be to
get rid of them all and just take a look
at another contour line that represents
a slight increase all right so let's say
you you're taking a look at a contour
line another contour line something like
this and maybe that represents something
that's right next to it like two point
one that represents you know another
value that's very close and if I were a
better artist and this was more
representative this would be it would
look like a line that's parallel to the
original one because if you change the
change the output by just a little bit
the set of end points that look like it
is pretty much the same but just shifted
over a bit so another way we can think
about the gradient here is to say of all
of the vectors that move from this
output of two up to the value of two
point one you're looking at all of the
possible different vectors that do that
you know which one does it the fastest
and this time instead of thinking the
fastest as constant length vectors what
increases it the most will be thinking
constant increase in the output which
one does it with the shortest distance
and if you think of them as being
roughly parallel lines it shouldn't be
hard to convince yourself that the
shortest distance isn't going to be you
know any of those it's going to be the
one it connects them pretty much
perpendicular to the original line
because if you think about these as
lines and the more you zoom in the more
they pretty much look like parallel
lines the path that connects one to the
other is going to be perpendicular to
both of them so because of this
interpretation of the gradient as the
direction of steepest descent it's a
natural consequence that every time it's
on a contour line wherever you're
looking it's actually perpendicular to
that line because you can think about it
as getting to the next contour line as
fast as it can
increasing the function as fast as it
can and this is actually a very useful
interpretation of the gradient in
different contexts so it's a good one to
keep in the back of your mind gradient
is always perpendicular to contour lines
great see you next video